foreign
good afternoon welcome to this baber
overview and scrutiny committee I'm
councilor John Hinton and I'm chainless
meeting today I first remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film or photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
[Applause]
we're also joined this afternoon by
Rebecca Hewitt corporate manager for
finance commissioning and procurement
by Fiona de timel director of growth and
climate change
Robinson corporate manager for
governance
and Dave Busby who is the councilor Dave
Busby who is the cabinet member for
finance
can I move to the agenda please any
apologies for absence
the chair we have apologies from
councilor Grandin
to receive Declarations of pecunia or
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
are there any to declare
no good
receive notifications of petitions
by the public
it was by counselors no
move on to item six which is BOS stroke
22 stroke 01 draft general fund and
housing revenue account
2023-24 and the four-year Outlook
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for finance to introduce the report and
report to the committee
thank you chair
um you may know the story of Peter and
the Wolf
where Peter cries wolf once too often
and when he does see the wolf nobody
believes him
and from my experience like talking to
counselors at the moment
when I suggest that we're having a tough
time financially and an even worse one
next year they all say oh we've heard
that before you always claim your heart
up and then you come up with a
Surplus
so this is your opportunity to prove
that this year we are serious about the
situation we're in and we want you to
nail it down so that the other
counselors will take it seriously what
we'll do is Rebecca has a presentation
which we'll go through but
will stop on the pert each pertinent
slide to try and get agreement or any
questions that you want on those
particular items before we move on so
we'll take it step by step
yeah getting the thing to work okay
thank you
um so we're here today to look at the
budget for 23 24.
um what we are focusing on today is the
assumptions that are making up that base
That Base budget so looking at
everything that we've assumed in pulling
our our base together and having a
chance to discuss those challenge those
and and agree if if we think that
they're they're correct and what we want
to take forward
so as a a bit of a backdrop
um to where we are this is the general
fund our medium term plan for 23.24 as
we forecast it back in February 2022 so
we were showing a net cost of service of
11.4 million and funding of 10.4 million
so back in February we were forecasting
that we would have a one million pound
budget gap for 23.24
some of our our assumptions at the time
we can see
um we were including a pay Award of two
percent plus the annual increments for
staff
we were forecasting inflation on
contracts of two percent and we were
assuming that our funding was going to
be flat so the same sort of levels that
we were showing at 22 23.
we're now well into 22 23 so we've moved
on a fair way since February and we're
all aware of the economic circumstances
and what's been going going on out there
and currently for our forecast for 22 23
we've got a pressure of 800 000 pounds
some of the key key reasons for that on
on this slide and detailed in the report
so the pay award has increased we are
now seeing
1925 per FTE so that's a 580
000 pounds pressure and that actually
works out across all of the staff at
around about eight percent increase
compared to a two percent that we had
forecast in the budget
also seeing Fuel and energy increases so
that's adding a pressure of about 80 000
and then we've got other inflationary
increases through material costs and
repair costs and and lots of other other
areas and that's totaling about 150 000
pounds
for this year
um we've got it we've got part of it
covered because we put 500 000 from last
year's Surplus into the inflationary
pressures Reserve
to cover some of that but we are
expecting the pressures to increase into
23.24 we're not expecting negative
inflation to come along and take take
all that pressure away and obviously we
can only use that Reserve once it's a
one-time only hotter funding
so looking at the current likely budget
Gap taking all of those pressures into
account and assuming that they're going
to continue we're looking at a a budget
gap of around 2 million pounds so it's
actually gone up from from 1 million to
around two
so in the in the report we have set out
all of the assumptions the key
assumptions within within our workings
um to challenge those and and to have a
look through those and so what we've got
on these next slides we've just got some
of those on each on each slide and we
can pause and take a look at those and
and consider each one in turn
so this one sets out the employee costs
initially so we have the pay award as we
discussed that's now
1925 per FTE in 2223
higher than any of us would have
expected
currently we are looking at a pay award
for 23.24 we're forecasting in the
budget four percent for that so that is
in line with some of our discussions
with other Suffolk authorities
um we're thinking about putting that at
four percent within our base budget
figures for 23.24
I've also got a pay review that was
committed to by councilors and the chief
executive in 2022 at the moment we've
had a very sort of broad Rush estimate
of 500 000 pounds in the
when it comes to pensions and we are
removing a lump sum contribution to the
pension deficit and increasing the rate
of that we pay against all employees as
an employer contribution
um and that's following a discussion
with Suffolk County Council and looking
at the position of the fund and that
will reduce costs so that's a a small
saving for 23 and 24 of 151 000.
and then we've got the vacancy
management factor that we have in our
budget currently it's currently at five
percent we are proposing that we keep
that at five percent for for staff
turnover and reflecting the fact that we
never have 100 of our staff in post at
at all any one time at all the time so
um because of the increase in staff
costs and staff
um staff costs from the pay awards that
would have a an increased
saving effectively of 83 000.
yeah sure
okay so I shall pause there then and
have a chance to take any questions
thank you um
Rebecca I've got a couple of questions
for you
um just to clarify some of it
um so the the adverse line pay award
that's in this current year
and that is the only pay award apart
from increments that people will will be
awarded that's the only pay award this
year which is eight percent
of their pay
and the yeah so the pay award for 22.23
was
1925 per FTE
um that's the only pay award
that works out around eight percent per
FTE when you when you take it across
yeah all of the staff okay so the four
percent that you're projecting for the
following year
um why have you chosen four percent
um it's
having had quite a big percentage this
year
you've assumed quite a big percentage
again next year
yes and that was that was taken on
discussion with the other Suffolk
authorities the truth is we we don't
know we're obviously to have no we don't
know what that is going to be it's
agreed nationally and it's very much out
of our hands
um
felt that there could be a pressure on
on pay that it could go up to four
percent
but if that's something that you know we
can we can discuss and review
but whatever it is will be mandatory on
you too yeah to pay
um
when is the the review taking place the
pay review is that underway now or
yeah
so we have consultants in we have um
that piece of work has been undertaken
is being undertaken currently
um I don't I don't have the details
myself of where
yeah
and I don't quite understand the 26 and
remove the lump sum can you
explain a little bit about that
yeah certainly so for 22 23
um there's an employer's contribution
based on each employee's salary which I
believe works out at 23 percent uh
employee but we also have a lump sum
that we're making towards the deficit
and pension fund deficit
the valuation has been positive the
latest valuation
um so in discussion with Suffolk County
Council we've reviewed what our
contribution should be
um what we are looking at is rather than
having a deficit contribution and a 23
percent
for for each each member of Staff we're
changing it to 26 and removing the
the lump sum deficit contribution
so it's difficult to see why it arrived
why you needed that lumps and when
you're you're keeping Pace by your
contributions into the pension scheme
we're 23 percent
is is that 22 not accurate then
it will vary from valuation evaluation
so the valuation will take into account
all of the
the Investments and everything that's in
the fund
um and that obviously fluctuates as the
market fluctuates so every three years
we'll have a reassessment of of what
that position is
um
staff
employers contribution is about
25.5 for
for local Authority staff isn't it
across authorities I think I think it's
set by individual
that's all my questions for the moment
thank you
pension they tend to do a full
revaluation I think every three years
and depending upon where you are you
either end up paying to fill a gap or in
this case it looks like we may be
overpaid or
evaluation of the pension fund has gone
up significantly such that we don't need
to to top it up so it's good news for us
otherwise we might have been adding even
more pain
[Music]
thank you
does that mean we've over put money into
it then
when you do the pension evaluate what
you need to put into the pension fund to
make sure there's enough pension in
there I mean that varies every year
people leave
different salary rates
fund valuation goes up and down
depending upon where it's invested so
it's almost impossible to get it 100
right each year um in the past we've had
a shortfall and we've had to contribute
to to bridge that Gap we fortunately
managed to do that and now we're in a
position where we can actually reduce
that lump sum payment so it's good
um but did didn't you say it was 17
it's normally 17 and this is 26 so
that's like a lot a lot more than it
should be in there
did you even mention 70 sorry I thought
so I thought you said
but what should the what should this be
then
well
according to the value as it should be
26 percent
which is what we're now paying
but but in three years time who knows it
might go up to 28 or down to 24 and or
they might ask for another lump sum to
to bridge a gap
it swings swings around each each year
every three years when they do the full
evaluation so
this is nothing unusual I mean it's good
in the past we have had a shortfall so
and that had been quite expensive to
fill that but we've no need to do that
anymore
are you are you happy with the
the assumptions that we've made on the
pay Awards
it's one
one question on the on the um pay Awards
the pay review
how did you arrive at the 500K
a as a very broad estimate of a
potential potential cost
um we obviously at this point we have we
don't know what that cost is going to be
so it was taken as a an amount per per
FTE and just as a very very broad brush
estimate of what what it could be so
that there's something something in
there
I did do you
kind of think well
the worst case scenario would be a
million and the best case scenario be
sort of 100 000 and we'll take the
middle point is that how you kind of
do it
yes we did consider different options of
what it could be so it could be let's
see it could be much higher we looked at
potential cost but yeah we did take the
kind of the Middle Middle Road on this
one
Rebecca when would we know a better
estimate when's the work due to be
completed
um so as Rebecca has mentioned we have
got Consultants working with the people
board at the moment
um it's difficult to say exactly when we
might know but they are in the stage of
starting to
um
look at job descriptions at the moment
so we would hope early next year we
should have some idea of of the kind of
scale of impact
would it be fair to say that you've just
assumed that everyone will go up by ten
thousand a year
or some winners and some losers
we don't
don't know until the work is complete
what it will mean obviously for
individual individual people so it was
just very
very how can we estimate what an amount
could be
no no real detail behind that at this
point
this point I think it's going to be more
like to be a grade and job specific so
somebody I don't know let's I don't know
what the grades are but somebody on a
grade set and in one area may get 10 000
where somebody on a grade seven another
area may not get anything because
they're
the job importance or difficulty in
filling the vacancies is Switched
so I think I don't think it's
straightforward as saying it's ten
thousand pounds per head
sorry won't it just be a job evaluation
not how difficult it is to fill that job
well it's part of a job evaluation I
think
it's no it's no issue saying jobs Jobs
worth thirty thousand if you can never
find anybody to fill it
because the job
is therefore evaluated at say forty
thousand
yes we're just having a look at that at
the moment in terms of the scope of the
consultant's work
um it is as you would imagine a very uh
detailed piece of work
um so it
it will be benchmarked against external
factors but it is obviously looking at
the grade as Dave said not not the
people
um
so yeah it but it I think that's why
we're being a little bit vague about the
amount just because
genuinely until we get into that piece
of work and where we will we will try to
sort of group
um similar roles in you know similar
graded roles we'll try to group those to
make the process a little bit quicker
but it is it is a detailed piece of work
that we're doing
a number of us have voted against the
senior leadership increase and here it
says the average increase is eight
percent does that mean that um some of
these people will be getting a
lower down the line are they getting say
a 10 or 12 because this is an average or
is this is this average really pulled up
because a lot of the people at the
higher end are getting a big increase
because they're obviously earning more
money
I mean when you look at National
averages it is just really shocking to
see this
this really
I mean I know inflation is going up but
these are really lot High
thing it doesn't bear well for baby to
have made this decision
well I know but what is it that's
drawing it can I just ask what is it
it's drawing up is it the the money at
the high end or is it increases for
people at the lower end which are larger
yes so the eight percent is the average
based on the
1925 per full-time equivalent so the
people that are lower lower paid on the
lower ranges about 1925 is obviously
higher higher percentage for them those
at the top end around the SLT level
obviously 1925 would be much smaller
percentage increase but that is the the
national agreed 1925 per employee and it
just happens to work out for for our
makeup of staff that is around eight
percent on average
I mean the key said hopefully it's
benefiting the people that need it most
by giving a higher percentage of the
people on a lower salary
I could just come in here and say
actually a higher percentage for the
people on on Lower salaries because if
it's based on 1925 pounds per head
full-time equivalent
um yes it's a higher percentage for
somebody who's only earning 20 000 a
year
but it's the
still 1 925 pounds
I'm not going to get more than that are
they
well no but if you get
1900 pounds and you're only on 19 000
and that's
a better increase than if you're on 90
000.
difficulty in that point of view I think
what we should be looking at here is the
fact that we're talking about 1925
pounds per full-time equivalent
the amount they're going to get because
to talk about percentages it's going to
vary enormously depending on the average
salary they're on now
as Melanie says that's the
designated increase so we can't really
do much about that
um
sorry come in on that this is a table of
assumptions it's not an assumption
though is it
no and that is a a known increase but
this table is seeking to do is to look
at what has changed since we did the
budget in February so in February we had
put in a two percent increase into our
2223 budget which then obviously feeds
on to 23.24 but in reality that increase
of the 1925 works out more like eight
percent so this is showing that there's
a pressure that will continue because
this year's pay award has been more like
eight percent than the two percent that
we had in the budget
ah
if I could just say I mean I don't I'm
I'm none of us are um
kind of uh
the officers are the experts at
um
dealing with government when it comes to
settlements and working out finances so
all we can do is ask the questions and
um
so yeah
which I think we've done for this
particular part of the table
okay so the next section in the report
which we're still looking at the general
fund is around suppliers and services
and contracts
and So within electricity we are seeing
some pressure from the increase in
prices from approximately 0.14 pounds so
14p per kilowatt hour up to 24.
the amount that we're including in our
budget assumes that there's been no
change in the use of the council's
assets um
90 000
got some better news when it comes to
gas in that our current contract has
been fixed until the end of September 23
so we're not seeing any pressure much
pressure there
and the majority of our use applies to
the Leisure centers and any increases
there should be recovered through the
contract with the provider
insurance premiums is an area where we
are seeing some pressure we have got the
contract being renewed from January
indications from the market is that we
can expect to see an increase in premium
so that these 10 percent from from that
on that insurance contract
similarly in shared legal service we're
expecting to see a pressure of around 27
000 based on previous years use of that
service and uplift for salaries and
other costs
within our contracts we've got a four
percent uplift on the refuse contract
so we have a cost pressure in 22 20
3 for the increase in staff costs and
then
of around 50 000 and then we've got
contract discussions still to be
finalized but we've assumed four percent
for the time being because of the the
pressure that
um that we know is is out there
and then shared revenues partnership
we've got an estimate based on
inflationary increases so as you'll
appreciate a lot of that is Staff costs
so we have included a 27 increase on
their currently 75
000 Pound Pressure
I'll pause there if any any questions or
comments or feedback
thank you
um could is
more of a breakdown possible on the
shared legal services that 11 is quite
significant
um I'd like to understand if that is
largely salaries it says other costs as
well so
is there any more information
I'm afraid I don't have any more
information on that currently but I can
certainly go away and find out what what
that has been made up of
I do have a question as well I'll guess
if we got a price fixed until September
23.
what happens for the next nine months or
seven months of the year I pursue is
going to go up but we haven't put that
in
the truth is obviously we we don't know
what that's going to going to be when it
comes to September um
and that is some some work that we are
continuing can continuing to look at so
we've all come back in January with some
pressures and savings options and that
will be part of it will involve looking
at some of these pressures and building
in anything else that we are
used to be known may still come but at
the moment that is our our best best
estimate for for what we've got in our
base budget
Sage of Omaha
as he's called but all the markets at
the moment are showing showing gas
prices falling
uh I'm presumably renegotiating the
price in the middle of the summer when
demand is probably down anyway so with a
bit of luck
they might come back into reasonable
proportions
yeah I think we're all all hoping that
uh Energy prices come back down again
next year
well electricity is slightly different
because it has to be generated whereas
gases just sort of sucked out of the
ground and sent off to somewhere and
with
five petroleum gas coming now from North
America and from Mozambique and
everywhere else reliant on gas from the
East and East isn't this uh have a
concern
all happy on this particular slide
a concern might be from my point of view
it might be on the the price of fuel for
vehicles
because that doesn't seem to Bear any
relationship to anything at the moment
it seems to be all over the place
I just can I just just note the
I mean the biggest item in that that
you've just gone through is the
the refuse contract
two and a half million
which is
a quarter of yes 25 of our in-house
are being spent on someone else's staff
um
so
I mean I guess this is a it's a contract
shared between all the
district councils and the borough in
Suffolk isn't it is that right
so do we get any um I guess my question
is do we get any um
benefit from having this
uh
what's what's the words from about
purchasing
with all the other districts
um there will undoubtedly be economies
of scale from bulk purchasing do we have
a breakdown of what that is no no I
don't think we have that today
um but but they will undoubtedly you
know they're even in fuel bulk buying
there is always an economies of scale
but we don't have those figures the
breakdown of that today
there's two elements to the increasing
the costs one is volume
every new house that we build and gets
bought requires additional collection
and then there's the cost itself of
the staff and vehicles Etc
um
how often is the
contract renewed
this is I'm filling in for Melissa today
as you probably know that on top of her
head I'm afraid I don't
um but the fact that it says that
contract negotiation is being finalized
and that does give us an opportunity to
obviously
negotiate strongly to drive down that
price as much as possible which is why
we put assumptions in at the moment so
rest assured we will be negotiating that
in so far as we're able to in terms of
the best possible price
does it go to competitive tender do you
know
foreign
I'm not sure to be perfectly honest I
know that there is an annual renewal so
um even where the the contract is set
for a fairly long period of time there
was an annual update to reflect growth
and prices I believe that's what this is
rather than a full recontract free
tender of the contract it's the the
annual annual renewal look at prices and
uplift
I think the key the key here is of
course the title at the top which says
assumptions
the moment there are lots of assumptions
being made because we don't know the
definitive answer at the moment
we have to base the budget on something
any other questions
so the next slide that we have is
looking at sales fees and charges and
the council's interest
so planning income we are seeing reduced
income in 22-23
due to the level of uncertainty out in
the housing market so our our starting
position for 23 24 is based on our 22-23
expected outturn and so we're seeing a
220 000 pound pressure as a result of
that compared to what we originally
thought we would see in 23-24
terms of garden and trade waste we are
seeing an increase in subscriptions for
the Garden Way service currently
we can we tell whether that will
continue but within our assumptions we
are assuming again that we're going to
use the 2223 forecast outturn as our
starting position for 23-24 and that
shows a slight uh saving or slight
benefit of three of 39 000.
building control again lots of
uncertainty in the market and
significant change in regulations has
kept income up a little bit for 22.23
and so at the moment we are leaving we
are assuming that that will be the same
as the 22-23 budget
in 23-24
in terms of Interest we have seen
interest rates go up for our long-time
borrowing though that is all at fixed
rates
um and we are seeing a slight reduction
in our costs just due to to repayments
on some annuity rate borrowing so that
is seeing an 81 000 pound benefit
for short-term borrowing we are seeing
some pressure and the cost of borrowing
is assumed to increase based on guilt
years forecast and we've not yet
factored in any new borrowing for future
Capital programs and we are seeing a a
increase of pressure for 2324 up to 850
000 on short-term borrowing
cause there for for question
the reason that it's it's so high
obviously apart from the interest rates
going up considerably is that over the
past few years we've benefited from
having short-term borrowing at very low
rates
fine
until we got hit with a significant
increase in the rates and unfortunately
a lot of those short-term borrowings I
guess have matured and we've now got to
replace them and
it seems as though one of the ways that
we would need to replace it is with
borrowing at these kind of rates
as it says there this doesn't include
any new borrowing
but any projects that we take on board
where we require additional borrowing
that will be on top of this 850.
foreign
chair the question follows then are we
assuming that there will be no new
borrowing
to look at pressures pressures and
savings we come back in January once
it's been worked through with cabinets
as well
um that we are pulling together a draft
Capital program and that will will feed
into this and obviously will be
scrutinized in the usual way and those
discussions and decisions will have to
be made at that point
will certainly be a greater emphasis on
a rate of return
we weren't just borrowing for the sake
of it not that these rates there'll have
to be some kind of material Financial
benefit the gun cited
thank you um just go back slightly to
Garden trade waste income
um
had I understood correctly that um we
won't be able to charge for that service
in the in the future and so therefore
that that income will disappear
mm-hmm
there is the recycling and waste
strategy coming I personally don't know
the details of what's involved with that
and what I do know is it's not impacting
in 23 24 I think it's following after
and my understanding is that the
government has said there will be new
burdens funding to to cover the cost of
bringing that in and further work will
have to be done as we understand more of
the details and we get more details on
on what that will what that will look
like and what the impact will be going
forwards
even though it's a it sounds like it's a
popular service that is you've got new
subscribers so people are happy to to
pay that because it's their choice is
there any uh lobbying to government that
you you can do on that
from our point of view yes I think there
will be
the problem is each of the councils
operate in different ways so
Baba uh will charge for the service
because we believe that if it's an
optional service then you should pay if
you choose to pick up the auction
whereas somebody like Ipswich
they don't they includes it in their
council tax so in fact the the brown bin
service is free but it isn't because
it's included in a higher council tax
but it apart from that there will be the
if they go down the
route that they're talking about then
there'll be food
waste collection as well which God knows
how much that's going to cost so
potentially what they're recommending
could be significantly more expensive
than what we've got at the moment
this is just the increase in the number
of bins that we will be collecting it
doesn't include any potential increase
in the price of
so do we
that's correct yes it's just the the
increase based on on numbers at this
point there's no no increase
there
and that that kind of discussion will be
for later this is
we're not asking you to come up with any
solutions at this point
we'll be looking at that over the next
month or so but these are really just to
get the base
levels agreed
when we introduce the brand been scheme
which is one of the first things I was
involved with when I came onto the
council near 20 years ago it was on the
basis that it would be as near as
possible a cost Mutual system across the
county but it paid for itself so on
occasions it's make makes a small profit
because we've got a lot a lot of the
balance between customers paying and the
cost of collecting their bins means we
have a slight Surplus other times it
will be costing the councils a slight
amount of money for the simple reason
that we have to put on another cart and
until that cart gets up to capacity
then
there's a slight sort of deficit on the
system so it's a swings and roundabout
system but it's as near as possible to
cast neutral across the system
but that could all as you say go up in
Up in Smoke if you like if they
compulsorily put in a freebie system but
as you consider that electric cars are
now going to be charged Road from tax
and that won't come in until 2025
I'm not quite sure how quickly they're
going to have changed the bin system
right
I think the time scale could be rather
long
fans I mean each each Brown bins any 50
pounds and they'll keep the browners
is whether we have seven things for
recycling or do we have four or do we
have three but we're not going to be
getting rid of the brown bins are we
but that the budget would have to
reflect all sorts of different things
because the more collection bins you
have
the more you have to modify your tanker
Fleet to collect them well yeah I've
just come from the from the West country
where they have all sorts of little
boxes outside of different items in they
have to effectively do what the murf
does on their doorstep
and the vehicles have come round I've
got so many little holes inside of them
completely unsuitable wrap for use
around here
so it's a it's a different thing
altogether but the point is with at this
point we're assuming for 23 24 that the
service will be largely the same
so we at this point we don't need to
worry about
councilor Lindsay do you have a question
uh
you can just go back to planning because
we've just gone over that so
it's assumed that that will continue to
end that will increase
getting I'm getting my fingers in
Brackets
quite right in the head so does it is is
that 220 that you
projected for
2023
a 220 000 Pound Pressure
so we're expecting the
income to go down
why why the
sort of forecast that's quite gloomy
reduce
worsened and tightened and we just have
seen less less planning applications and
less income coming in and that's in line
for National the national picture so and
we are expecting that continue into 23
24.
I think that move is probably prudent
when you consider we have something like
10 years worth of government targets of
housing with permission now
which means that there's hardly any need
for any new positions to come forward so
there's bound to be a downturn in the
number of people applying for
permissions
and that probably applies more to the
big developers than anything else
there's a lot of them out there but
we've also seen that because the jlp has
been effectively refused there are a
number of large
plans included in the jlp
that are now in limbo really and would
face pretty stiff
from locals counselors and from the
planning offices so those schemes may
not come forward so there could be quite
a big chunk of income that we don't get
so so the delay in the glps actually
cost us a lot of money then
well you could say that I'm not certain
I would have totally agree with that
that it probably hasn't done us any
favors
okay so the the final slide for looking
at the general fund is our funding and
our income
for the government grants we haven't had
any any indication of what this will be
yet for 23 24.
um I believe we're expecting a draft
settlement on the 21st of December from
central government for that and but in
the meantime we're assuming that that is
going to be a similar level to 2223
um there's no indication that we're
going to get severe cuts and there's no
indication we're going to get increases
either so for the time being we've had
to assume that that will stay stay flat
we have amended the new homes bonus to
show the latest latest growth figures so
we're assuming that that will continue
on the same basis and the same
calculation as last year
um but there will be a slight a slight
drop potentially in the amount that we
receive about Just 4
000.
for council tax we have worked through
the latest tax base figures you'll see
on the slide those figures are
highlighted in yellow because they do
differ from the latest information we
had at the time that the report went to
print
so the report had a 2.5 percent tax base
growth which was based on the overall
growth position in housing and an
estimated we have now worked through the
actual growth and translated that into
band The equivalents so what we are
seeing now is a 1.6 increase in tax base
giving a 99
000 pounds benefit in 2324
the current budget position is showing a
Bandy Increase five pounds
um that was the maximum possible without
a referendum
the government did announce last week as
part of its Autumn statement that we
could increase up to three percent so
districts up to three percent and then a
social care Levy for those authorities
with the social care function could have
an additional two percent up to five
percent
the five pounds that we've got in our
budget currently actually works out at
2.82 increase so
um although there is some flexibility to
go up to three percent now that would
have a benefit of 11
000 pounds so um not a significant
significant impact
we've also got the local council tax
reduction scheme potential increased
from 95 to 100 that is currently out for
for consultation and if that does come
in we'll have 164 pounds pressure and
result of that
in terms of business rates and it's very
difficult to estimate currently what
that will be and so we are assuming a a
similar similar position to 22 23
and then a slight growth as part of the
Suffolk pool and we've estimated two
percent growth on that
so I'll pause there for any any more
questions or feedback
I think we can just say that you can see
there that
two of the big numbers are dependent
totally on what the government decide
they want to do
it's very difficult at this time to be
able to predict we're not very
optimistic so they may be the best case
scenarios
the lctrs impacts although it's
projected to cost us 164 000. I think
we're hopeful that in the fullness of
time
change in the in the way the
calculations are done and how the
frequency of the calculations it will
make SRP more efficient
therefore we hope that we'll recover
that cost
with a lower charge
comments or questions cancels
just just
just on the new homes bonus I've kind of
lost track of
because the government keep changing
things and I
um
what what was the what was their last
position on what they'd be doing with
the the new homes bonus
we were expecting to see a a complete um
review of the the funding mechanisms and
the new homes bonus
because we haven't seen anything yet and
there's not going to be time to do that
for this financial year we have had to
assume that they will roll it over and
we have had advice from from Pixel who
who give us advice and do modeling on
local government funding generally and
that is their view also is that it will
roll over in the same
position for 23.24 and obviously we'll
keep looking out for any
any new advice or any consultations and
reviews of the funding going forwards
so have I got because my assumption was
that they'd settled along that they'll
be phasing out in and if they don't
produce review won't the phase out
happen
then
and therefore will the
the impact on
on us
be
worse than it was in the previous year
if they're phasing out more of the new
homes bonus
actually it has phased out to a degree
so we have seen some amounts come down
there were some Legacy payments that
have reduced
I don't know at this stage what what the
future of that is going going to be so
um I'll have to keep you updated as that
that progresses
thank you
um as there is
estimated to be quite a big hole in
finances is there any work on finding
efficiency savings aside from everything
that we've looked at now
yes there is there is a separate piece
of work going on to look at what those
could be
um what efficiency and savings options
there are and also any other pressures
that that may be new um so that is
currently going sort of through the SLT
and then it will go through cabinet as
and then it will come back to yourselves
in in January to review that
each team has been targeted with trying
to reduce their budget
and they've given a lot of thought and
time to it we have some estimates but
into the into our into our budget
calculations yet
it's not likely to be 2 million is it
let's face it
no it's probably more likely to be um
changes in service levels
hold on
Council Lindsay please
I was just savings alone probably won't
help meet this Gap so there is a
separate Group which will feed into the
budget time scales that Rebecca just
mentioned
the question for you Rebecca from me
we've been saving money in here this
morning because the heating hasn't been
on
um
where where do the costs regarding
our reduction in accommodation and
everything else
in Endeavor House appear Within These
figures
or don't they
so those those reductions in costs are
already included in our base loan
figures so the 2.32 million gap has
already has already got those reductions
built into it
are we um are we going to move to a
debate or
I don't know whether to reserve what I'm
going to say
[Music]
according to the papers according to the
papers we're looking at both of these
aspects together
just carry on tonight so we can carry on
look at all we if you would prefer to
look at them in two separate bits then
we can look at it no no I'll just
um suggest
um my my thoughts are
that there's we are unlikely to to see
savings coming through efficiencies or
income to close that Gap
um otherwise you you would be presenting
that more forcefully today I think
um
at what stage do we say we can't really
afford to apply that uh pay review which
is
which is possibly 100 half a million
because I the way I see it yes you can
do it but it could lead to staff
reductions
so carry on and then later on consider
oh can we actually forward or last off
so then we start looking at staff
reductions which I don't think is what
staff actually want
and I was just going to
um respond I guess by saying that today
for overview in scrutiny it's really
about have we got the right assumptions
I'm not sure if that's what you're
asking but at the moment until we've
done work and you know there are some
unknowns uh around Philip sort of
meeting that Gap but but these are the
assumptions we're presenting to ons
today and and um I guess we you know it
would be useful for us to have some
feedback on those assumptions
um maybe that was some feedback on those
assumptions but
um they're the ones that we are looking
at the moment in terms of assumptions
well I appreciate it you're looking at
two million pounds nothing's going to be
off the table
we have to produce a balanced budget
story
I think it's fair to say that this the
papers in front of us show that there's
this 2 million
Gap
the assumptions are in there which show
how without two million gap has been
arrived at
it's up to us to say whether we think
the right assumptions have been made or
whether there are some assumptions that
haven't been included or could be
included
not to actually come up with a figure
that is going to
either reduce or increase the two
million gap
it seems that there is already a work in
progress to try and reduce the Gap by
making some Savings in various
departments but that is not for us to
decide here and now it's for us to
comment on the assumptions that they're
being made
I agree but it needs to be flagged up
we'll take that on board as
is one of the many ways that we
hopefully can get to the two million I
mean from my point of view my concern is
if I was the government I'd look at that
new homes bonus line and say well that's
paid you've had all the new houses why
do you need to be paid an extra bonus
for it I'd be looking if I was going to
try and save money that's the way I'd do
it if I was the government
I think it's probably like in too
political I think it's probably fair to
say that that was said some time ago but
they've taken their time about doing
anything about it to our benefit at the
moment
they will move on to the the housing
part of the
okay so look at the the position for the
HRA
so look at 22 23 we were projecting a
budget surplus of 500 000.
we have seen some pressures as you could
imagine in 22-23 so the pay award
equally has had an impact on the HRA as
it has done the general fund we've also
seen significant pressures on
subcontractors and increases in material
costs
and we are expecting all of those
pressures to continue into 23 24. so for
22 23 we're actually looking at a budget
deficit of 16 000 on the HRA compared to
a surplus
um in the budget of 500 000
so this slide shows most of the
um the expenditure and income impact for
for the HRA and so when we look at the
pay award again that's the same 1925 per
FTE
we've also projected a 2324 we're
including four percent for the the
national pay award um which I've said is
out of our out of our control
um but we're including four percent for
that at this point
we've got a the pay review within here
as well
pension it's the same same position as
for the general fund so the increase in
the in the employer contribution and the
removal of the lump sum contribution
also premises cost repairs and
maintenance at the moment we're looking
at CPI of around 10 percent and this is
based on our Quarter Two forecast and
expectation of inflation continuing into
23 24 and not reversing and so that is
the biggest impact that we're seeing on
the HRA is around repairs and
maintenance costs so 1.4 Million Pound
Pressure being included in the 23-24
budget for that currently
so contractors
um we are projecting a 10 increase and
also for supplies materials and tools
so that's based on our experience of 20
2022 at the moment plus an inflationary
increase
gas and electricity
um we've had an estimate
from saviles based on a sit for
projections and we're looking at 100
increase in costs for the gas and
electricity for the HRA
um a total of 272 000
water costs again we're seeing an
increase around 10 percent
and then external interest on loans
um so there's no no increase on those
um because most of the the borrowing for
the HRA is fixed long-term loans
um so we're just seeing a small impact
on that
I will pause there for any any questions
or feedback on those
foreign
sorry the the the I may have missed this
when you outline it the total
uh increase
is
uh
a lot larger than the
now a lot larger than 400 and
am I looking at the right oh I see yeah
so
we've got in our papers total assumed
increase in expenditure
of 2.2 million
and that I think says 2.3
56
has gone up slightly is that right the
the increase in
or is are we just looking at a rounding
thing
mind you there's difference between 2.2
and 2.357
because how
to
um I'll check whether that has come from
yes there have been some changes in some
of the the staff numbers I believe
the biggest issue here is obviously the
premises costs
which as it says it's the to all
materials it's staff
it's in addition
Consultants where we have to bring them
in we know we've got an awful lot of
work to do in
a lot of our properties we've been
criticized
for the state of our houses so we can't
get away with assuming that we're not
going to be spending a lot of money on
on this
Point yeah thank you Mr chairman on the
point of the maintenance and repairs we
are going through a period of
transformation in the Building Services
I think that includes a diagnostic
analysis of all the the work that's
being undertaken so
um until we actually get to the end of
that tunnel where we get some more light
the the costs will increase rather than
decrease but at least it will lead to
eventually in about two to three years
it's not going to be short term it's
going to be longer term then the costs
will start to come down but as councilor
Busby has alluded to we have got a lot
of properties out there that were built
in the 60s and 70s and are going to need
a great deal of work spent on them and
and that's where we need to ensure that
those properties are built brought up to
a standard that is suitable for our
tenants so it's going to get worse
before it gets better but it will all
the work that's going on in Building
Services it will get better
Council Lindsay
um
the assumptions for the increase in
contractors costs
and supplies equipment tools
and water are all 10 why are they so
much larger than the Assumption for the
pay award
um I can't tell you exactly why they're
larger than the pay reward but what they
are is um they're based on a
contractor's price so they will be based
on
um what the average is showing uh under
uh market conditions and that could be a
combination of factors and contractors
can be pricing and additional risk for
example which so is more than just
contractors salaries it will be the the
other factors that wrap around that and
I suspect I don't know that without
talking to the individual contractors
but I suspect there'll be pricing in
greater risk but
basically we have less control
over those things we have no control
over those things really
negotiate but
we've all seen what's been happening in
the building market in terms
of
results
thank you did I miss something why is
gas and electricity 100 increase
yes I don't know the detail behind
behind the gas electricity and the hras
I'll have to take that one away
um
the follow-up on but I do recognize that
that is different to to the pressures
that we are seeing in the general fund
so I'll pick that one up
presume is our houses is it John
sorry Mr chairman yeah it's the
sheltered housing accommodation as well
as the temporary accommodation so and
it's the communal services within some
of those where we've got leaseholders
and mixed tenure
so that they're not
for the same kind of negotiation we have
with the larger contracts with our
suppliers they're more
down to the open market I guess
can't negotiate a bit better as soon as
you know we're a good a good customer
and uh
we're good for the money
compared to British gas we're dropping
the ocean aren't we literally
comment on British gas after what was
said in the in the cab report and stuff
um yes it does seem a bit I agree with
Council Barrett it does seem a little
bit Stranger in talking about gas and
electricity 100 across the board Bonk
then you look at our service charges
Waters up 11 whereas we're budgeting on
water up 10
um heating charge eight percent service
charge five percent
uh we know that
while we assume that energy prices are
at their maximum about now and could
shoot in Theory start to come down
uh unless the French start pinching all
our electricity because they're unusual
power stations aren't working
um
it just seems a little bit excessive at
100 perhaps
not going to make an awful lot of
difference to
um to final figures but uh
I'm not convinced that we are repeat yet
in terms of I don't think we are at the
peak in terms of energy Supply prices
yet and we also don't know what the
government's intervention was only going
to last until it was in the middle of
next year or something so
the lady knowledge
happening I haven't got onto that yet
we're just about to go on to that now
yep so that the next slide has the
income assumptions so for dwelling
rental income at the moment we have
included five percent applied to our
current housing stock
um and at the moment we've not put any
new build figures into that into that
estimation
um so if we're looking at a 1.1 million
increase in mental income as a result of
that
garage rents we're assuming no increase
to garage rents
um it's hard to let and the sites are
under currently under review
service charges so we've got five
percent
service charge eight percent Heating and
eleven percent water and that's in line
with the rental increase and utilities
charge to meet 50 of the funding Gap
so yeah again I'll I'll pause there for
any any questions or comments on those
and why why are we assuming that we're
not gonna
build any or have any Council additional
Council stock in in that year
a matter of of not having those figures
and not knowing what that will be
um we can look at that as part of the
the next stage of the development of the
budget and when we look at pressures and
savings and
look at that then
as possible
yeah thank you Mr chairman we actually
have a Target to acquire or build 65
each year over the next five years
obviously that will depend on where we
are with the budget situation
um when we um come to setting the budget
when we sit when we set that figure in
the HRA business plan uh we don't have a
crystal ball we won't have All Affair of
these cost of living crisis Etc that was
going to come forward so we may possibly
have to reduce that Target for one year
two years three years
depending on what other cost pressures
we've got within the HRA retrofitting is
one I've been bringing our properties
back up to standard is another one and
making sure that our repair service is
effective and efficient and making our
properties the standard that they should
be so there's all those balances to
think out before we look at now how many
we're going to acquire or
or build obviously from my point of view
I want to continue acquiring and
building new homes we desperately need
them the register is going up it's not
going down so the need is getting more
and more but we do have to look at the
balances a bit like going around and and
twisting the plates Robert really to see
what's more important they're all a
priority as far as what counselors are
concerned but I think once we get to the
budget setting process we will have
identified what those priorities are and
then would be more understanding of what
actually we can build or acquire in
respect to properties over the next year
two years or three years
I hope that answers your question
I could just clarify a bit so do do we
have is there something in the
housing business plan now that states a
number of houses that we want to build
in the 22-23 year
so we're making an assumption
assumption that we're not going to build
the 65 houses that were in the they're
in the business plan
which is
um
shouldn't that be
shouldn't we make the assumption
that we are going to stick with a
business plan and then we have an open
discussion about whether we want to or
not and we put whack up the the budget
Gap
and you know it's part of the saving
maybe it's part of the sayings we need
to make maybe we should make it in the
salary Cuts maybe it could be somewhere
else but
it looks like something some assumptions
here have about where we're going to
make savings have been made I.E about
how many houses we're going to build
a business plan I think quite rightly
set a target for the number of houses we
would like to build sorry or we
what we need to build is probably a
completely different figure it's
probably considerably higher
it all comes back as well as to whether
those properties are available for us to
acquire and that depends upon the
development
of housing across the district in in
total because it's linked to the 35
percent
affordable housing Target that is on
most planning applications so if they
don't come come forward we can't build a
house we can't acquire a house that
hasn't been built yet
so it there are so many variables
involved I think it's probably the wise
move to say let's assume we don't have
any because if we do have 65 houses it's
not going to sort of rock the boat as
far as these figures are concerned but
it is going to happen to contribute
slightly towards them Council Osborne
without running the risk of joining into
the debate with the greatest respect Mr
chairman it's not about how many
properties will come forward I'm sure
we'll be able to acquire or to build 65
providing we've got the money to do so
it's more about the budget itself rather
than what's coming forward from
developers or land that we acquire to
build our own it's about twisting the
plates and and coming up with the budget
to deliver on all those priorities and
needs that we've got coming forward
yeah I mean Robert are you right there
will be some either new built or new
acquisitions between now and
the end of 23 24 Financial
for which we will get some rent at this
stage we can't we we're not prepared to
predict that I mean
we've had some new builds the biggest
change will actually will be in the
perhaps the five percent we I think we
heard today that we may be allowed to
increase the rental by seven percent
which would make quite a significant
difference to these accounts
having said that
seven percent is quite a big increase
for our Council taxpayers to pay
so we've got to try and balance that off
but that again is something that we'll
look at in the future
when we come to put forward a balanced
budget
so sorry you've raised another
question now that where does the seven
percent come from it talks about five
percent in there I think the government
have issued uh they normally have a
ceiling that you can increase your rents
by
they came out for consultation on a
three five or seven percent alternatives
we assumed
that it probably would be five percent
um and that's what we've built into this
it appeared
decided probably as a result of what
everybody was saying because it's it has
a significant impact
I mean it doesn't sound a lot five
percent seven percent but it's an
ongoing two percent Gap and it
within two or three years you could be a
million pounds short
they've come with a bigger figure but
these are the situation is really fluid
all of these are our best estimates as
they were earlier yesterday as tomorrow
we might need to change a few of them
but we can only go with what we know at
the moment
I'm sorry how does so what's the is
there a currently a cat
well how much has counts how much have
we put up Council rents in the past I
guess is my question
well Jen could probably answer that but
again we've had government fixed
uh terms they for a few years it was
uh minus one percent and then it then it
was plus one percent and so it goes up
and down but
yeah
yeah councilor Busby's absolutely
correct uh for five years we had to
actually reduce it by one percent year
on year and you never catch up on that
so there was great losses there so once
that that five year was passed we went
into a period where we could start to
increase them we averaged it on two and
a half percent increase
this year for the 23-24 budget members
are going to have to make a really hard
decision on it there will be a member
briefing to make members aware of the
impact if they do or if they don't
increase the rent we've just been
talking about the HRA budget and what
priorities we've got and how we may not
be able to deliver on all those
priorities so obviously what we charge
for rent if we do increase the rent will
be a big question for members coming
forward
um I think as councilor Busby has said
you know if we don't go with the seven
percent we lose that year on year and
you never ever catch up on that so but
it averages
um Robert about between two two and a
half I think it was last year it was two
and a half percent
I think it was a
uh a price index Plus at one percent
yeah
yeah councilor Busby would you please
respond to questions rather than carry
on the debate with other people in the
chamber thank you sorry sir
just a just a quick point on this of
course it does highlight how complicated
all these finances are and the
assumptions that have to be made or
cannot be made
um we have to do a balancing act here
we up Castle has rents does that
increase our bad debt
proportionally
um
it's it's a difficult difficult decision
for us all to have to make
we can only start from one place and
this is the start point but the
assumptions that we've made as to what
the budget could look like and the final
final figures will come before Council
in February
any other points
cancel that can I just make a request
that when we do have to discuss whether
it's five or seven percent or whatever
but the figures are given to us as the
actual rent that people pay because
it doesn't it doesn't mean anything
unless we understand that really
portfolio holder financing is taking
that request on board so
portfolio holder for housing has taken
that request on board so
any other comments on the housing
Revenue cap or questions for
portfolio holder and the offices
no oh
to perhaps a trivial point in terms of
the sums but
I get okay well I don't quite get why
we're assuming no
house
new houses but I'll accept it
um the assumption
you're also assuming no increase in
garage rents zero percent
uh you're assuming a five percent rental
increasing rents but a zero percent
increase in
rents for garages
um
okay there's going to be no new garages
but you're not putting the rent up on
the existing ones what or you're not
you're assuming we're not
we're not um what's the reason for that
have you seen the state of our garages
Osborne
for our garages so if we increase the
rent that will demand go down even less
so let's keep the income that we've got
coming in from them rather than increase
it and lose some of that income it may
be the right thinking it may not you may
not agree with it but that's the
thinking behind it
I know from my own on my own Ward that
the garages are uh too small
in actual fact very few of them have
cars in them partly because they're used
for storage and partly because they were
on the basis of a a low ground rent for
a lease on the site and they put their
own garage on them a lot of which are
asbestos
which they can't afford to dispose of
and so they're left to sort of rot in
situ and so the whole situation of
garages across the whole district is
going to have to be a very complicated
one to sort out to decide whether we're
going to build some decent garages on
there and put a decent rent on them if
there's a demand or whether we're going
to turn them into houses
not the garages themselves but I mean
build houses on those sites
it's complicated to say the least
any other points on that
well I think we can
thank you very much indeed for the
question for the answering the questions
and presenting that
um
I think we can go into a debate now
anyway to decide what we want we want to
do
um thank you Mr chairman I thought we'd
we counselor Lindsay we've already
baited a lot of this already
probably so but it means it means it
shouldn't take as long to come up with a
proposal then should it
there are some recommended there are
some recommendations in the in the
papers
uh draft budget assumptions are set out
in the report for the
2023-24 general fund and the housing
revenue account budgets be noted
and then it says the committee may make
further recommendations as it deems
appropriate are there any other anything
else you would like to add to that
well
point is really it's early I I felt this
meeting was taking place quite early
considering the budget is not until
February and it's difficult for us to um
get you know there's so many
uncertainties and as you say Rebecca
thing the figures will change probably
will change quite quite a bit till the
final budget is is approved but
um it is a concern you know because
there's a lot of assumptions are
uh worst case scenario possibly
um and it's it's difficult for us to to
decide if that is realistic at the
moment or or too pessimistic or who
knows
um but um it is very early in the in the
process
I think probably we should note that for
next year see we we should monitor this
and see if it
early for when we when we get to
February and we are approving a budget
does it look very much like what we've
what we've seen today and then we might
have to decide next year or some of you
who are elected decide next year is it
really
good idea to start so early
when it's going to be subject to all
this all this uncertainty
that's possible
thank you Mr chairman I agree with
Melanie it is early but from the point
of view of counselors who are not aware
of things that go on within the HRA or
the general fund it's a good thing to
have on the table although it might be
changed and although there are
circumstances that could alter it and
make it a lot different I think it was a
good a good presentation from our from
our offices and thank you very much
but you know I still think that the more
you know beforehand the better you are
placed when it comes to the decision
making thank you
chair can I just add that councilors
last year felt that everything was too
late so we've tried to bring it forward
this year so that you did have a look at
the assumptions
um that were being made and could feed
into them if you thought that they were
woefully out you know way out
um so that the idea was to try to bring
it earlier to see if we could you could
get something more out of the process
really but um you know it's difficult
actually isn't that early when you think
about it we're at the end of November
by in three months time February we've
got to have an agreed balanced budget
and in that process that's that will
come to a cabinet in January
um there'll be no member briefing in
December it doesn't give us a lot of
time to to batten down the hatches
as I said my introduction
um
Patron the wolf our Peter was Catherine
Steele who has taken her hat where she
pulled the rabbits out of and
disappeared so we're in the process of
trying to replace the hat and the
rabbits
sorry
so
I think it's it's important that we that
councilors understand and accept that
the next three months are going to
generate some difficult conversations
we can't leave it until after Christmas
before we start having these
conversations
I think it's important as well that
we looked at these assumptions because
next month is a normal member briefing
and we want to have something
I won't take concrete for them but
certainly in the in uh close to the
final stages of preparation for the old
member briefing before it then goes on
to cabinet and then of course we have
another look at it
in January
to decide
um
on our final sort of uh looksie at it
Council Osborne thank you Mr chairman
I'm very um what's it not actually
thanking our
two councils here counselor Busby
councilor Jan Osborne up for their for
their input into this which has been
very helpful and thank you Dave thank
you Mr chairman
well I'm just wondering if we should
note this but also note that the big
ticket items
are completely dependent on the whim of
the government and
and the markets
um so
I'm not sure we can
you know
they're trying to gaze into a crystal
ball we we're trying to gaze into a
crystal ball but
you know I'm not sure we can add much
value really
so I think it's worth noting that that a
lot of the assumptions
are um yeah are sort of
dependent on things that we can't
control
and have no real why there are
assumptions rather than facts if we knew
exactly what was going to happen it
would be a lot easier agreed
um but I think we should probably
it's not straight towards the
having a sniper government or any or
anybody else for that matter but if we
are going to put something to that
effect together that we note this
assumptions report
but the basis for the assumptions is
liable to change
because of factors outside of our
control
can I just say it's certainly been a
very useful exercise I think new
challenging the assumptions because
you know with these guys are looking at
the numbers all the time you can get
what number blindness almost
so it's useful to have counselors to
provide some kind of level of
review
thank you Mr General I propose that we
go with the recommendations that before
us
chair I have to do hands
they'll have a show of hands and members
on this one
The Proposal is that it's the
recommendations around to put those in
your papers all those in favor
thank you chair that is unanimous
good decision because if you haven't
approved it would have brought you
another one back next week and the week
after and the week after until you
bloody well that improved it
that concludes the meeting uh councilors
so thank you very much indeed for your
participation and your use for combat
comments